Now that we set up the desktop and
Android backends,
you are probably wondering about
the iOS and HTML backends.
Well, the HTML backend is kind of hard
to run because you need to be running
Gradle tasks from the command line.
The IOS backend is even more difficult
because we need to first provision
a device for debugging,
which requires Xcode and some time.
Also, as you might be aware, all the iOS
system APIs can only be accessed from
Objective-C or Swift, which makes
running a Java game kind of tricky.
We're not going to set up the iOS or
HTML backends for now.
But we've created bonus levels
explaining how to set up both,
which you can check out by following
the links in the instructor notes.